>> TREY: GOOD EVENING.
I'M TREY GOWDY, AND IT'S SUNDAY
NIGHT IN AMERICA.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
HAVE YOU EVER WONDERED WHY WE
HAVE GOVERNMENT IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
HAVE YOU EVER WONDERED WHY WE
CONSENTED TO BE GOVERNED, WHY WE
GATHERED OURSELVES TOGETHER AS A
PEOPLE AND SUBJECTED OURSELVES
TO THIS THING CALLED LAW?
WHETHER IT'S THE LOCAL, STATE,
OR FEDERAL LEVEL, THERE HAS TO
BE A PURPOSE, A REASON FOR
JOINING HANDS AND FORMING THIS
THING CALLED GOVERNMENT.
AND THEN ALLOWING THAT
GOVERNMENT TO PASS AND ENFORCE
LAWS, WHICH CAN INCENT AND
PREVENT INDIVIDUAL ACTS AND
DECISIONS.
WE ARE AFTER ALL A NATION OF
LAWS AND NOT A NATION OF MEN AND
WOMEN AS JOHN ADAMS FAMOUSLY
SAID.
EVEN AS I POSE THAT QUESTION,
I'M SURE THERE ARE WORDS AND
PHRASES GOING THROUGH YOUR MIND.
YOU MAY BELIEVE THAT EDUCATION
IS THE PRIMARY FUNCTION OR
RESPONSIBILITY OF GOVERNMENT,
ESPECIALLY AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL.
PERHAPS YOU BELIEVE IT IS
REGULATING COMMERCE OR PROVIDING
FOR OUR COMMON NATIONAL DEFENSE.
PERHAPS YOU BELIEVE THE PURPOSE
OF GOVERNMENT IS TO SAFEGUARD
YOUR NATURAL RIGHTS.
PERHAPS YOU BELIEVE IT IS TO
PROVIDE A COMMON CURRENCY OR
BUILD AND MAINTAIN OUR ROADS AND
BRIDGES AND AIRPORTS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT GOVERNMENT,
ACROSS ALL THREE LEVELS, LOCAL,
STATE, AND FEDERAL, ALL OF THOSE
ANSWERS ARE CORRECT.
BUT I WOULD LIST SOMETHING ELSE
FIRST.
I WOULD START WITH SOMETHING
ELSE.
I WOULD LIST PUBLIC SAFETY
NUMBER ONE.
PUBLIC SAFETY IS THE PREEMINENT
FUNCTION OF GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S WHAT I BELIEVE.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ME.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE VERY
BEGINNING, THE PREAMBLE TO OUR
U.S. CONSTITUTION, YOU WILL SEE
THIS, WE THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES IN ORDER TO FORM A
MORE PERFECT UNION ESTABLISH
JUSTICE, ENSURE DOMESTIC
TRANQUILITY, PROVIDE FOR THE
COMMON DEFENSE, PROMOTE THE
GENERAL WELFARE.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE PHRASES HAS
SOMETHING TO DO WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY, WITH LAW AND ORDER, WITH
PROTECTION.
SO WHEN I SEE SPIKES IN CRIME, I
VIEW IT AS BOTH PROOF OF WHY WE
HAVE GOVERNMENT IN THE FIRST
PLACE, WHICH IS BECAUSE EVERYONE
CANNOT BE COUNTED ON TO TREAT
THEIR FELLOW CITIZENS WITH
RESPECT AND DIGNITY, AND I ALSO
VIEW RISING CRIME RATES AS A
FAILURE OF GOVERNMENT TO MEET
ITS NUMBER ONE PRIORITY, AND I
DON'T CARE IF IT'S A REPUBLICAN
OR A DEMOCRAT OR ANY OTHER
PARTY, POLITICS IS A VERY LITTLE
SIGNIFICANCE, IF YOU'RE DEAD,
INJURED, ROBBED, OR ASSAULTED, I
NEVER HAD A POLITICAL
CONVERSATION WITH A CRIME VICTIM
OR A COP OR A FELLOW PROSECUTOR.
NEVER.
PUBLIC SAFETY IS TOO IMPORTANT
TO BE JUST ANOTHER POLITICAL
TOOL.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, EVERYONE DOES
NOT SEE IT THAT WAY.
WE HEARD THESE RIDICULOUS CALLS
TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
WE HEARD EVEN MORE RIDICULOUS
CALLS TO ELIMINATE THE POLICE.
WHAT WE NEED THEY CLAIMED WAS
REALLY MORE SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
YOU LET ME KNOW IF THAT IS THE
FIRST THING YOU THINK OF WHEN
YOU'RE BEING ASSAULTED ON A
SUBWAY, OR YOU HEAR SOMEONE
BREAKING INTO YOUR HOUSE, OR GOD
FORBID SOMEONE PULLS A WEAPON ON
YOU, YOU LET ME KNOW WHETHER YOU
WANT TO CALL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PSYCHOLOGISTS OR CALL THE
POLICE?
IT WASN'T JUST THE CRAZY CALLS
FOR DOING AWAY WITH THE POLICE,
THERE ARE ALSO THESE SO-CALLED
PROGRESSIVE PROSECUTORS WHO HAVE
TAKEN OVER SOME DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY.
THESE SO CALLED PROGRESSIVE
PROSECUTORS CAN'T FIND A SINGLE
SOLITARY PERSON THEY THINK
SHOULD ACTUALLY BE IN PRISON.
IF YOU WANT TO SPEND YOUR CAREER
KEEPING GUILTY PEOPLE OUT OF
PRISON, YOU SHOULD BE A DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, NOT A PROSECUTOR.
AND WE HAD THE MEDIA EXCUSING
ACTS OF VIOLENCE CALLING THEM
SIMPLY PROTESTS.
EVEN ONE MEDIA PERSONALITY
ASKING WHAT MAY BE THE SINGLE
DUMBEST QUESTION I HAVE EVER
HEARD ASKED, WHICH IS, QUOTE,
SHOW ME WHERE IT SAYS PROTESTERS
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE PEACEFUL.
OKAY.
I WILL.
IT IS CALLED THE LAW.
IT IS CALLED A CRIMINAL CODE.
IT ACTUALLY LETS YOU KNOW YOU
CANNOT STEAL PEOPLE'S THINGS
BECAUSE YOU ARE MAD.
IT ACTUALLY LETS YOU KNOW YOU
CANNOT SET THINGS ON FIRE
BECAUSE YOU PERCEIVE SOME
INJUSTICE.
IT ACTUALLY LETS YOU KNOW YOU
CANNOT INJURE A COP BECAUSE SOME
OTHER COP DID NOT MEET YOUR
EXPECTATIONS.
THE LAW ACTUALLY HELPS US
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE,
BETWEEN AN ARSONIST AND A
PROTESTER.
BOTH SIDES HAVE SHOWN A
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN THIS
RELATIVISM, EXCUSING THEIR OWN
SUPPORTERS FOR ACTS OF
LAWLESSNESS.
BUT I DO NOT.
ANYONE CAN FOLLOW A LAW THEY
AGREE WITH.
ANYONE CAN ACT RESPONSIBLY WHEN
THINGS ARE GOING THEIR WAY.
THE TRUE TEST OF CITIZENSHIP IS
CAN YOU FOLLOW A LAW YOU
DISAGREE WITH?
CAN YOU ACT RESPONSIBLY WHEN YOU
ARE DISAPPOINTED?
EITHER WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS
OR WE ARE NOT.
AND WHEN I REFLECT ON THE RISING
HOMICIDE OR MURDER RATES, I
THINK OF ALL THE PROMISE AND
POTENTIAL THIS COUNTRY OFFERS.
AND THEN I WONDER OF ALL THESE
FREEDOMS AND LIBERTIES WE ENJOY,
HOW MANY OF THEM ARE OF ANY USE
WHEN YOU ARE DEAD?
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, FREE EXERCISE
OF RELIGION, THE RIGHT TO
COUNSEL, WHAT USE IS ANY OF THAT
IF YOU ARE DEAD?
SO YOU CAN PUT ME DOWN AS
SOMEONE WHO BELIEVES PUBLIC
SAFETY IS THE PRIMARY FUNCTION
OF GOVERNMENT, AND WHEN CRIME
BEGINS TO SOAR, AND THERE ARE
MORE AND MORE INNOCENT VICTIMS,
YOU CAN PUT ME DOWN AS WONDERING
WHAT IS THE USE OF GOVERNMENT IF
IT CAN'T DO THE MAIN THING WE